[Applause]
so it is our last episode of the season
and right now we don't know when we're
coming back or if we're ever coming back
you know like your dad so I wanted to
take a minute tonight to talk about what
drew me to not safe with Nikki Glaser
you know besides the with Nikki Glaser
part it's really cool but in the past
year I've talked to foot worshipers
professional cuddlers escorts porn stars
strippers sugar daddies young couples
old couples dudes on tinder pegging
enthusiasts so many incredible comedians
and guess what everybody has sex we're
all doing it that guy over there isn't
but that the rest of us are it's crazy
to me that we're all here right now
because some dude was just like oh and
by some dude I mean your dad every one
of your dad's some of them even louder
than that and those are the ones who
aren't coming back but I know I know
that talking about sex is uncomfortable
and it makes people all like like how do
I explain this to my children and it's
like your children your kid came out of
your vagina so at least you can do is
exist blame to them what one is and
please don't tell them to call it a
downstairs or a front bottom it's yeah I
don't know I can actually kind of like
front bottom we can keep that okay my
parents honestly never gave me the sex
talk which is why I talk about sex all
the time now you made your bed mom and
dad and now I'm talking about banging in
it because sex was such a taboo subject
in my household I didn't masturbate
until my mid-20s so like like yesterday
I'm 32 so by the time I started
masturbating I felt like the Billy
Madison of jacking off I felt stupid
left behind and I could only do it if I
was staring at a picture of Chris Farley
dressed as a bus driver
don't do that to me you guys stop it
here's the thing I think it's important
that we all talk about sex and here's
why because he's talking about sex yeah
this guy and not just the adorable stuff
he says about wanting to date his own
daughter Oh oh my god I love engagement
photos
it's disgusting last week Trump told
young girls everywhere that if they're
sexually harassed at work they should
quit or find a new career in other words
someone please sexually harass Donald
Trump I beg you
his BP Mike Pence is talking about sex
he's also talking about what kind of
haircut he might get from like the Lego
factory next but mostly sex he said that
if elected he and Trump will appoint
Supreme Court justices who will overturn
Roe vs. Wade you know just like he
overturns baby turtles in order to feel
joy Mikey likey you need to talk about
sex because these states are talking
about sex and they're all trying to pass
legislation about it like North Carolina
and their transpannic bathroom laws or
Mississippi with their religious freedom
act even Indiana tried making it legal
to discriminate against the LGBT
community but thankfully people rebelled
until their governor caved in
and walked it back who wait who is their
governor oh right the turtle murder guys
we have to talk about sex when we're
quiet and we treat sex like it's
shameful or weird we leave a void that
anyone can fill with their own personal
hang-ups or religious beliefs and that's
where hits the fan and I don't mean
that in like a fetishist sort of way no
offense Jim
be honest about it cuz look I'm sure
last week not everybody wanted to hear
the story about the time I found a
Monistat 7 cap lodged in my vagina that
had been there for over a year but isn't
it better than pretending that we don't
lose mana set seven caps in our vaginas
right if you're like I was and are
ashamed of yourself for what you're into
if you hate that you watch porn or that
you like to lick feet or that you get
turned on when milfs get hit in the face
with pies you're not alone the the MILF
pie guy might be because we broke up but
he dumped me he said I got too old but
sex is all around us in fact sex is us
it's how we got to be here it shouldn't
be something we're ashamed to talk about
so stop whispering be loud be honest
be open it should be celebrated when we
say like I have sex
[Applause]
I'm just a normal person who has sex
sometimes you know it's much guys don't
be quite about sex be loud about it talk
about it we'll be right back
hey this is Nikki Glaser and this is the
part of the video where I tell you to
watch more of my videos but I'm not
gonna tell you what to do instead I'm
just gonna look at you judging Lee